an uncertain cinematic future Bland
antagonists poor critical consensus was
one of these the reason the latest DC
flick failed to bring in the big bucks
this weekend or or three it now seems a
Shazam Fury of the Gods is yet another
commercial disappointment in the DC
Superhero Blockbuster realm it's opening
weekend boxoff has taken the
neighborhood of 30 million dollars Falls
well short of its reported 125 million
dollar budget and some of the film's
cast and Crews seem to be assuring a
defensive posture online star Rachel
zegler recently took to Twitter to decry
quote senselessly meme responses to the
movie and called it actually very good
meanwhile in a comment on Reddit that
was since deleted Fury of the Gods
director David F Sandberg made this
intriguing statement I saw where this
was heading a long time ago I'll be
alright though I got paid all my money
up front you don't need to be a box
office analyst to see that Shazam Fury
of the Gods has experienced a softer
than expected opening weekend and has
been met with a collective shrug by much
of the viewing public why did it happen
it's not something that can be pinned
definitively on one factor but there are
several possibilities as to why the fury
of the Gods opening weekend ended up
being more like a minor tantrum of the
Gods Everyone Knows by now that the DC
extended universe is in a transitional
period with the projects already in the
pipeline when James Gunn and Peter
saffron took the creative Reigns of the
live-action DC Comics franchise making
their way onto screens the future of
every big screen DC Superhero is now in
doubt with the upcoming The Flash
purportedly serving us a reset to the DC
Cinematic Universe as we know it that
means that a movie like Shazam Fury of
the Gods is caught in the middle with no
clear indication whether it's Plus or
characters will be parts of the larger
DC tapestry in a perfect world a comedy
adventure Blockbuster like this would
stand on its own but with a cinematic
ecosystem being the way it is now those
connections to a larger Saga tend to be
significant you can see just south
significant this factor is by comparing
and contrasting the commercial
performance of films within the Marvel
Cinematic Universe to those in the dceu
Shazam is a very important character in
DC Comics and it's possible that there
will be some place for him in future DC
cinematic projects but that place seems
currently up in the air and the film
might be suffering commercially as a
result not even a last minute pitch
revealing an appearance by Wonder Woman
in the movie could neutralize this
threat pattern parcel with behind the
scenes shake-ups at DC HQ is the fact
that audiences have grown weary of what
big screen DC Comics adaptations have to
offer Shazam theory of the Gods is that
the first DC movie to get a tepid
response Black Adam also qualifies for
some measure as a box office bomb and
even James Gunn's Take On The Suicide
Squad managed to earn that designation
as well there's a reason that the Warner
Brothers Chiefs have decided to reset
the DC EU and take it to their new
Direction find enthusiasm and dependable
box office receipts just aren't there
and that does more opening weekend and
for Fury of the Gods is only the latest
example of that in action there does
seem to be some positive Buzz building
around the Flash and his twin Batman of
Ben Affleck and Michael Keaton are a
good not so secret weapon to have in its
Arsenal so it's definitely possible that
audiences and fans can be energized
about these characters again but Fury of
the Gods isn't the project to make that
happen perhaps it would be a different
story if Shazam Fury of the Gods had
actually delivered on the promise of the
post-credits scene in the first movie in
what has been called the biggest failure
of Shazam Fury of the Gods the prospect
of a film featuring The menacing Mr Mind
as its Chief antagonist was once again
punted down the road no offense to how
the mirin or Lucy Liu but the super
villains and fury of the gods have a
generic monotonous quality compared to
the quirky threat that a super
intelligent criminal worm like
Mastermind can provide Concepts like an
evil telepathic worm are a big part of
what makes superhero comics special but
it all too often feels like their big
screen counterparts tend to shy away
from anything to offbeat or weird
however love it or hates it you have to
admit Ant-Man quantumania is an
exception to that phenomenon a Shazam
sequel featuring Mr mind could have been
just a creative shot in the arm the
franchise needed for box office success
the days of film critics being able to
make or break a movie's box office
fortunes are probably long gone but
critical consensus can still matter to
the public especially when a film like
Shazam Fury of the Gods is on otherwise
Shaky Ground Fury of the Gods currently
supports on emerald green 53 Tomato
Meter score in Rotten Tomatoes as
critics have taken aim at the film's
purported weaknesses its lack of focus
and its failure to recap to the
lightning in a battle success of its
predecessor some viewers will disagree
of course and the film is scoring much
better on the audience side but it's
still tough to Discount a poor critical
consensus for a film that many
prospective viewers were probably
already on the fence about going to see
anyway for them enough bad reviews just
might have pushed Fury of the guards
from check out in the theaters to I'll
just wait for streaming
[Music]